[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد بوجوه غالبيتها جديده
لمقاعد حكومته بدا الرئيس التركي اردوغان
ولايته رئاسيه الجديده ومدتها خمس سنوات
وضمت التشكيله الوزاريه خمسه عشر وزيرا
جديدا فيما تم الابقاع على وزير السياحه
والثقافه وكذلك على وزير الصحه اللذان
حافظ على منصبهما وبدا لافتا تعينوا رئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات الاسبقها كان فيدان على
راس الدبلوماسيه التركيه فيدان وزيرا
للخارجيه قد يمهد هذا بحسب مراقبين لتغيير
جزئي او كلي في سياسه تركي الخارجيه وخاصه
بما يهم بعض القضايا العالقه وابرزها
الملف السوري خاصه وان وزير الخارجيه
الجديد
كان له دور البارز سابقا في الملف السوري
وكذلك في الملف الليبي واما عن التنصيبات
الوزاريه الاخرى فيرجح خبراء ان يحمل
تعيين نائب رئيس الوزراء الاسبق محمد هشام
شاكر وزيرا للخزانه والماليه في الحكومات
الجديده تغييرا في اداره التزامات تركيا
الاقتصاديه حيث قالت تريتورز ان تعيينه قد
يمثل خروجا على سنوات من السياسه
الاقتصاديه غير التقليديه للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من
دمشق الصحفي غصن يوسف ومن اسطنبول والكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا من اسطنبول لسيد اوغلو
تسمعني صحيح
نعم اسمعك جيدا ممتاز مساء النور سيد
اوغلوس اسمح لي ان ابدا معك بتعليق بعض
الاتراك فيما يخص هكان فيدان
البعض استذكر سؤال طرحه صحفي والاكيد بانك
قرات هذا التعليق يقال بانه صحفي سالها
كان فيدان وقال له سيد الوزير نحن لا نعلم
من انت لا نعلم الا وجهك فاجابه هكذا
بالقول بانه يكفيني ان اعلم عنكم كل ما
يلزم من تفاصيل التصحيح في الواقع ان
يقوله رجل المخابرات عادي ولكن ان يقول
رجل استلم منصب وزاره الخارجيه وهو المعني
بالتصريحات والحضور الاعلامي فسؤال مطروح
هل يمكن ان ينجح رئيس مخابرات سابق في
تقلد هكذا منصب حساس كذلك نتحدث عن راس
الدبلوماسيه
تحياتي لك في البدايه استاذه ريم وضيفك
الكريم والاستاذه المشاهدين يعني يجب ان
نغفل بان السيد حكان زيدان نعم هو كان
رئيس دائره الاستخبارات التركيه على مدى
العقد الماضي او اكثر لكنه كان منخرط بشكل
كبير في العديد من الملفات على راسها
السوري يعني خلال العوام العشره الماضيه
الملف الليبيا الملف العراقي ملف
حتى العلاقه التركيه المصريه تطورت التي
شاهدناه وتبعناها خلال الفتره الاخيره
الماضيه تتابعين او لاحظت خلال يعني
السنوات الماضيه الامور يعني هي كانت
النيه بشكل كبير يعني كان تبدا الشق
الامني ومن ثم تتحول الى الشق السياسي لذا
انا التصور عن السيد هكان فيدان هو يعني
كان يعني يعلم كما ذكر فيما يتعلق
بالمواطنين ولكنه يعلم بالملفات المنطقه
بشكل كبير وعلى وجه الخصوص يعني الملف
السوري وخاصه كما تابعنا في ديسمبر الم
اول اجتماع على مستوى وزراء الدفاع عقد في
موسكو كان برفقه وزير الدفاع التركي انذاك
كان فيدان سيد غسان هل ترك ضيفي بانه موقع
غسان غسان
حضوره فيما قبل كذلك في المحادثات
الاستخباراتيه ثم يتعلق بالملف السوري قد
يساهم في حلحله هذا الموضوع وهذه الازمه
تمام ريم يعني هو المقال
اليوم وهو يتحدث يعني عن هذا الموضوع
كان من الذين بادروا الى الاتصال مع
الجانب السوري وكان له زيارات وكان هناك
لقاءات يعني مع يعني مع المسؤولين
الامنيين ولذلك اعتقد اليوم يعني بان يعني
الملف سينتقل معه الى وزاره الخارجيه وهنا
يعني ربما سيكون هناك
اعتقد نوع من التفاهم بين البلدين خصوصا
يعني ان الوسيط الروسي يدخل بشكل قوي وحتى
الوسيط الايراني ومن مصلحه البلدين اعتقد
يعني ان تتقدم المفاوضات باعتبار ان يعني
اللاجئين تؤرق البلدين
ويسعون الى حل ايضا هناك مشكله يعني تفكيك
المجموعات الارهابيه ومواجهه المجموعات
الانبطاليه في شمال شرق سوريا ولذلك يعني
هذه في التشكيله الوزاريه اليوم يعول
عليها انها يعني انها تعرف الملف السوري
بشكل كامل وانها تستطيع ان تتعامل يعني
اتفقت معه على انها كان فدان قد يكون
النقطه الايجابيه في حكومه اردوغان
الحاليه لحل ازمه سوريا ولكن هذا يعني
كذلك بان المشكله في السابق لم تكن سوريه
المشكله في السابق كانت تركيا عدم حلحله
هذا الموضوع او هذا الملف لعدم قدره تركيه
على طرح حلول حقيقيه
نعم يعني هناك كان في السابق تتذكرين يعني
كان هناك قلق وخوف تركي فيما يتعلق
بالمجموعات الارهابيه تتذكرين انقره
عمليات عسكريه منذ عام 2016 اخيره كان في
19 ومن ثم كان العام الماضي تابعنا سويا
كان هناك تهديدات دائما
عمليه عسكريه لملاحقه عناصر قوات قصد لذا
انا التصور اعتقد بعد هناك التطور المسار
الجديد في العلاقه ما بين انقره ودمشق
وبالرعايه روسيه خلال الاشهر الاخيره
الماضيه ان اتصور انقره بعد الانتخابات
وبعد الفوز الرئيس اردوغان ما اقصده هو
طالما اتفقتما على ان هذا الشخص قادر ان
ياتي بالحل وهذا الشخص اتى بعد تحضير
وزاري او بعد حكومه جديده
فالمشكله في تاخر الحل تتحمله تركيا وليس
سوريا هذا السؤال
لا هو ليست تتحمله تركيا كانت هناك بعض
المعوقات الصعوبات في الفتره الماضيه
وخاصه يعني كانت تتذكرين يعني اضرب لك
مثال الملف السوري تقريبا منذ عامين كان
هو ورقه يستخدم من قبل المعارضه السوريه
انقره والحكومه اردوغان هي سحبت هذه
الورقه من يد المعارضه هناك تطورات
اقليميه بشكل واضح يعني تغيرات وانقره هي
يعني تاقلمت بعد التغيرات وخاصه بعد يعني
عوده يعني سوريا الى الحضه العربي وايضا
هناك الراعي الروسي والعلاقه الجيده ما
بين الاتراك والروسيه ساهمت بشكل كبير في
تسريع هذا المسار ما بين انقره ودمشق خلال
الاشهر الاخيره الماضيه سيد غسان حتى وان
كانت الاجواء ايجابيه حضرتك تعلم بانه
الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل ما التفاصيل
التي يمكن ان تعرقل عملها كنفدان بحسب
قراءتك
لا يمكن القول يعني ان الاجواء ايجابيه
كثيرا يعني تعرفين دائما كما قلت لحضرتك
بانها يعني الشيطان يكمل والتفاصيل يعني
بين الجانبين هي كثيره وكثيره يعني هناك
تراكم حوالي اثني عشر عاما ولذلك يعني
اعتقد بان التفاصيل ستكمل بمن هي
المجموعات الارهابيه التي يجب ان تفكر كيف
يمكن التخلص مثلا من المقاتلين الاجانب
كيف يمكن
للجيش التركي ان ينتحر ما هي كيف يمكن ان
تعدل اتفاقيه اضنه كيف يمكن مثلا ان يكون
هناك اتفاقيه جديده كيف يمكن الاتفاق على
مثلا محاربه حزب العمال الكردستاني الذي
تعتبره تركيا ارهابيا وسوريا تعتبر
امتداده انفصاليا ولذلك يعني هناك الكثير
من القضايا التي ستكون شائكه وانا اعتقد
لان المفاوضات ستاخذ وقتا طويلا وربما
يعني سنوات ولكن انا اطرحه سيد اوغلو على
فكره انا لما طرحت فكره الاجواء ايجابيه
لانه السيد اوغلو قال وكانه هناك جو
ايجابي شيء ايجابي اضافته هذه الحكومه
الجديده ولكن يبدو سيد ان التقييم مختلف
بين الاتراك والسوريين ثم يتعلق بتوصيف
هذه المرحله ان كانت ايجابيه او ان كانت
تتضمن عراقيل عديده
يعني انا التصور النعم يعني في الوقت
الحالي هناك اتحدث لك بان انقره سوف يستمر
هذا المسار هذه هي ملامح السياسه الخارجيه
التركيه والحكومه
الحاليه التي يعني وضع رسم
وضع العنوان العريض لها حكان فدان لكن نعم
هناك كما ذكرنا هناك الكثير من القضايا
والمشاكل وخاصه نتحدث بان انقر هي فقط لا
تسعى للدرجه الاولى للهدف الاساسي من
التطبيع مع دمشق وهو مكافحه الارهاب هناك
موضوع اللاجئين لا تنسي بان ان انقر بعد
اشهر قليلا مقبله على الانتخابات محليه
يجب حل هذا الملف باقصى سرعه هناك تريد
خطوات سريعه من قبل النظام خلال المرحله
المقبله وهذا يعتمد على الخطوات التي سوف
يقدم عليها كل طرف ناهيك على ان هناك هدف
اخر وهو انقره دائما تركز عليه وهو موضوع
الحل النهائي وهو بفق القرارات العموميه
22 54 هذا ممكن ان يسبب مشاكل في المرحله
القادمه ما بين الط
السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات